there are now multiple ai models that
can depict through imagery anything that
you can dream of
you can either let the ai come up with
its own styles and ideas or through
prompting get as specific
as you want
and you can get quite specific
now not everything has to be fantastical
we can for example just depict a hotel
lobby
now you might notice that some of the
depictions have a sort of drawing or
rendering feel to them this seems to be
the default artistic style so to speak
for the model that i'm using here which
is mid-journey but through some clever
prompting we can elicit some other
stylings so for example maybe we want
more of a cartoon style we could also go
for more of a sketch style
now getting more realistic seems to take
a bit more effort from this model but
still somewhat doable with keywords that
influence the model to try to generate
imagery to match more high quality
renderings so for example here we have
an initial prompt and then some keywords
to indicate a higher quality
image i wish i could say i've got this
down to a science but i actually wound
up just writing a program to append some
keywords to the end of the prompt for me
and just trial and erroring until i got
imagery that i was happy with beyond
adding more detail as a sort of styling
and keywords you can also influence
things like colors so for example maybe
you want a black and white themed hotel
lobby or maybe you want blue and gold or
you want a hotel lobby but the floor is
lava
all of the images shown so far have been
created with mid journey which is a
discord based text to image generation
application mid journey produces the
highest quality images that i've seen so
far from text to image ais but it
struggles in one area in particular and
that's with realistic looking images if
you're looking to make imagery that's
artistic or conceptual or rendering like
there is no question that mid journey is
probably exactly what you're looking for
but what if you're after realistic
looking images what i mean by that is
images that don't look like they're
renders and instead look like actual
images of real life even if maybe they
look like they're photoshopped or
something like that but realistic real
life looking photos
for this there's actually an entirely
open sourced and free model that you can
just go and download called stable
diffusion now there are also options to
pay to run the model in the cloud the
one that i would recommend that you
start with is
dreamstudio.ai if that's what you're
looking for so if you don't want to fuss
with making the model run locally or
figuring out how to run it in the cloud
for you
i would check out dreamstudio.ai that's
the official kind of cloud application
for stable diffusion
but if you do have a local gpu with
about 10 gigabytes or more of vram or
you just want to run it on cpu and ram
locally or in the cloud just a little
bit slower then you can actually just
download the entire model and run it
open source from huggingspace for free i
will be putting links to all of these
things in the description so definitely
check out the description if you're
looking for like anything that i'm
bringing up here i'll have links in
there so let's compare these two imagine
you want an image of darth vader
go-karting with mid-journey the imagery
that you'd get might be something like
this
or this now don't get me wrong i love
this imagery from mid journey these are
awesome
but sometimes we want something that
looks real and not conceptual from
stable diffusion we get well darth vader
actually in a go-kart in realistic ish
looking imagery
and those images are still very
unlikely
so what if we want to return back to the
hotel lobby example
but with blue and gold theme
again the results that we see here are
far more like realistic and plausible
looking actual photos as opposed to
design or concept or render like imagery
so
what do we do
with all of this both stable diffusion
and mid journey are in what i'd call
active development they're both
constantly getting better plus they're
just simply not alone here there are
quite a few other text to image models
in development right now and likely
going into the future this is truly just
the beginning and also while the
resolution of something like stable
diffusion is 512 by 512 you can combine
this with upscalers which is exactly
what's being done with the mid-journey
images that i've shared here there's not
yet an upscaler specifically associated
with stable diffusion but there are
quite a few upscalers in the wild at
this point and i am sure many more to
come as these models become more widely
used with both mid-journey and stable
diffusion i can see them being viable
right now so things like environments
and characters and costumes and all that
kind of stuff seem to be really well
done by mid journey for example but mid
journey isn't the first and it's
certainly not the last text to image
model to be
artistic in this way
next i think stable diffusion like
models are a very clear and obvious
incoming replacement for like stock
photos and imagery
it's less artistic compared to mid
journey but can make some pretty
impressive stock photo imagery as well
as other more realistic looking photos
of whatever you want which is where mid
journey at least for now suffers a bit
so for example say you want a conference
room here's one here's another one and
another we can essentially make infinite
unique images of whatever we want just
by essentially just changing a random
seed there are other things that we can
tweak too but that's really the only
thing that you have to change
but these images they don't have to be
so boring so for example what about a
porsche 911 we could get even more
specific what if we want a porsche 911
in the mountains
maybe another
you get the idea
maybe instead we want a portion 911 but
in the jungle
you got it
how about a porsche 911 on the beach
okay maybe everything is just too easy
what about a portion on 11 surfing all
right that was a little harder but
surprisingly okay i'm not sure what i
expected with that prompt so how about a
porsche 911 in your living room
a bear
scuba diving
a robot
climbing a tree
so i think you get the idea but we're
not done yet one of the other
interesting things that i just sort of
stumbled upon just playing around that
i've honestly not seen anywhere else
show with these models is how well they
can like mesh things together so one
example of this is using a prompt at
like a as b
so for example we can do people to
illustrate this and the first one that i
discovered was an attempt to combine
elon musk and bill gates with a prompt
that was just simply elon musk as bill
gates for an iconic
elongates
which i promptly shared with the world
and likely disturbed many but it doesn't
stop there another example is elon musk
as mark zuckerberg and these are just
like so interesting to me with how the
features of the two are just
blended together pretty darn well like i
can see both of them in in this human
that has been generated but imagine
trying to do that in like photoshop and
really capture the essence of these two
individuals all in one it would be a
hard task i think whereas this this just
figures it out and that's really cool to
me
now to make these i usually just
generate a handful about 25 at a time
with random seeds and then i just find
ones that look good but it honestly
doesn't take that long to do so how
about another example how about brad
pitt and john oliver again here are the
here are actual photos this is brad pitt
john oliver combined
again i can't help but just be
impressed with how well this model can
mix the two and you can just see them
both in there you see it
they're there but also combined do i
think that is so cool now i don't quite
know what to do with this capability but
there it is you don't have to combine
people either you could combine other
things like porsche and truck
and now you have some porsche trucks
similarly to a recent video i made with
bloom a massively large language model
that's just been released for free to
the world these are models that have
historically been accessible really only
to a very small group of people and now
they're just plain generally available
for either a very low price like mid
journey or for outright free like in the
case of stable diffusion i think that
we're going to be learning a whole lot
more about what we can do with models
like these over time and i just like i
couldn't be more excited to see how this
really does like change the world i know
it sounds like super cliche to say
something like that but these are like
really really powerful and creative
technologies that are just barely
understood by people to leverage them
even to the point that we've shown so
far also i'm just struggling with just
keeping up with the proliferation of
these models and like i said with bloom
most people in the world don't yet even
have an idea that this technology exists
so we're really just seeing a very tiny
and honestly just biased group of people
mostly developers who are tinkering with
these models but that won't be the case
for long especially as entities like mid
journey despite being paid it is a very
cheap way for someone with absolutely no
programming experience at all to
generate images through an application
now if you are curious about the blue
model that i've mentioned a few times
here i'll also put a link to that video
that i did in the description along with
all the other links that i'll be putting
in at any rate i think it's really
important to reflect on like three or
four years ago image generation models
were basically 50 by 50 resolution
images
of things like just human head shots
where it could just make more human head
shots you couldn't specify what you were
looking for and all that
now we're at 512 by 512 imagery of
basically anything that you want or can
think of it doesn't even have to have
existed before so i'm finding it really
hard to even imagine like where will we
be in just a year from now what about
five years 10 years well if this
progress like continues at this pace
it's going to be insane yet again i find
myself saying
what a time to be alive and playing with
this sort of technology and neural
networks deep learning all of that
if you're interested in learning more
about neural networks you can check out
the neural networks from scratch book by
myself and daniel kukiyawa by visiting
nnfs.io
and like i said links to all the things
that i've mentioned here are in the
description i highly encourage you to go
check out these two models if you can
pay for mid-journey do it i think it's a
good price if you can't afford
mid-journey that's fine i think there is
a free trial you can still just use your
free trial and then be done
play with these models it's so it's just
really cool to kind of play around and
tinker around and the more people that
we get kind of playing around and
learning about these models the more we
can together learn what can we actually
do with these models but like i said i
think
i think both mid journey and stable
diffusion are honestly ready for they're
like commercially viable right now like
if you're a game developer and you're
trying to you know design um some
character or some boss or some
environment like this would be a it's a
really cool way to get concepts and
ideas
and if you're looking for stock photos
and imagery stable diffusion can do some
really impressive stuff especially if
you're looking for more typical stock
photos but if you want something
unbelievably specific stable diffusion
can do that for youtube right now and
again it's
it's free
it's just it's it's it's crazy it's
crazy to me so um with all these things
you do want to be careful i know mid
journey has a it does have a license and
i want to say you can use it
commercially up to
a business of like earning a million
dollars anyway you'll have to read like
the actual like licensing agreement to
find out if you can use it commercially
or what you have to pay to use it
commercially but like i said i i think
no matter what you know mid journey
won't be the last paid one and at least
for now i think it's cheap enough to
wear like i said i think it's it's good
because you don't need to be a
programmer at all to use it and for
stable diffusion you can also just use
dreamstudio.ai
and pay a little bit that way again you
don't need any programming knowledge or
expertise at all but if you do have
programming knowledge and expertise you
can run it locally and do all kinds of
cool things and just kind of just play
around so for example like i was saying
with like the meshing i tend to generate
like 25 images at a time it's a little
cost prohibitive to do that on
dreamstudio.ai but locally who cares so
anyways uh
really cool stuff i
i just i can't believe what's coming out
right now and including the stuff that's
for free but also mid journey despite
being paid it's a really well done app
it's so fun i've spent so many hours
just like
making stupid images on mid-journey that
probably no one will ever see
but it's just so fun and it's very
addicting and then with stable diffusion
i like i said i think i think we're
not we're still going to have stock
photo websites and stuff but
i think it will be ai based like stable
diffusion is so it's really exciting to
see where we're headed and to like start
thinking about where will we be
so anyways that's all for now until next
time
you